you go to a massage place at Night My
Buddy accidentally went into one did he
yeah because did he call the cops after
I think most guys would just be like no
that was weird
they just go oh no no thank you I think
that was 11 times yeah so you turn that
song yeah my friend had a back problem
so why did he flip over
so he's looking for places and he found
one on his way home from work it was
like those Chinese places they do it in
the big room so he asked the front desk
do you guys have anything more private
because he's also kind of heavy and a
guy showed up pulls out like a notebook
with all these girls on it and he goes
do you think she's cute he's all like
yeah she's pretty cute a girl comes in
and he's like wait a minute and then she
just knocks him off and then he finished
he goes can I still get that back
massage and she was like laughing
because she thinks it's a joke she had
to go to another massage place to get
another bag is this your friend MO again
MO mitsuwara